hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back you beautiful people to
our Oni I still haven't been pronouncing
that right since I started this but that
doesn't matter ok so this guy bashed a
hole in the wall what is that is that a
stomach or a kidney or some enlarged
gall bladder I have no idea but this guy
bashed a hole in the floor so I can drop
down to here
who dies Yahtzee is my favorite video
game reviewer he's fantastic
everyone should watch him zero
punctuation he's phenomenal anyway
unlock the door good so I think I need
to find a die to put in there maybe so
that I can complete that puzzle so I'm
being I'm just spastically saving here
door is locked door is not locked
oooh scribbling all over the walls do I
need to move these hey wait I want to
see the scribbling let me see the
scrambling man okay so there's a bunch
of script but it ends abruptly here
something seems off about these wallet
paper oh stop it with a blade shared to
reveal a door
cool hey look
yeah chuckle Oh Oh what the hell
you kidding me whoa what the hell
holy crap about to die good good good
good good good good good good good let's
get outta here
Wow Wow we ha ha all right I got the
heebie jeebies all over from that I love
how this game just throws unexpected
things in all over the place
okay so what's up with that can I like
can I cut that in anyway no that's just
a thing all right let's put the die here
OOP there we go oh it reveals a code
does it well I'm gonna write this down
so it's dot dot dot dot dot dot dot dot
dot dot dot dot dot dot dot if I knew
Braille this might make more sense dot
dot dot dot dot and dot dot dot dot dot
perfect I love that code it makes so
much sense to me in my brain cuz I am
the super smart Asst I've I'm so oh I
did i did i did i did i did i d-- like
okay so there's a thing maybe it is away
the hole is too dark to see down maybe I
could throw my lighter down there that'd
be some no then me on that would not be
smart that's not smart my only source of
light I cannot throw that down there so
I have a code and this code means
something and this painting means
something but what Oh what does it all
mean so
now that I have a code let me look at
this it's they're all it's just a
sequence of numbers well it's not a
sequence of numbers it's a sequels of
shapes so I got to figure out where
these shapes go so did this door unlock
maybe the door is locked maybe I could
pick it no apparently not this door is
unlocked still I heard something did you
guys hear that it's like a rumble maybe
that's just outside okay maybe there's
something in the cast this room gives me
the creeps now I don't know why it's
just rather unsettling haha hi there the
closet okay no not gonna do that so
there's got to be some place that I can
input these symbols shapes and/or
numbers I just it's just a matter of
finding at this point so I'm trying to
just use everything everywhere like I've
been taught in the past but that's not
that doesn't seem to be happening now so
we go back downstairs maybe there's
something here something in the church
you think here maybe there's something
to do with this there's got to be
something to do with this I found a
stick here but ah okay I got it
no all right here we go this is it so
press this one first press the button
yes press this button yes press this
button yes press this button yep and
press this button
babushka and last button right here
sweet yeah suck on that all right take
that you big blue monsters purple
whatever purple blue I don't really know
what you are I'm gonna call you purple I
guess
okay so there's some weird things on the
ceiling there oh goody I was wondering
when it's gonna get super demonic and
horrifying oh wait it got that way 10
hours ago
whoo look it's another shape that's the
same as the painting up there but what
does it mean what does it mean one open
good hopefully I'll get cornered by a
monster and die
that's just be my dream come true dark
and error oh good I always love these
parts these are my favorite this is my
favorite my favorite ever ah
so we're getting slowly filled in here I
took a piece of it cool Oh what would
that do what that do light it okay good
Oh God suddenly got the heebie-jeebies
all of a sudden I got the heebie-jeebies
oh no oh no it won't open
why won't it open why won't it open I
won't open do I have to put the piece
back okay alright so apparently I need
to do something about this I can't get
the new piece just yet until I have a
piece that I can replace it with maybe
I'm thinking that might be the thing
it's her candle in here there's no kata
later there's no candle in here
there's no candle in here there's no
candle in here loser kid lady Vicki okay
there's a candle all right there we go
hurry sorry it's just ah gotta be I
think I do know that Jenna don't
actually know that you in the legend oh
where do I go where do we go what I do
Oh what do i do what do i do what do i
do what do we do okay
go away okay alright we're good we're
good we're good we're get it we're good
we're good
you know that's a pretty beefy candle if
we can light up this whole place it's
quite impressive I do say so myself
okay so can't open that can't open that
this door is locked but there's a shiny
in there that I need I will have the
shiny
I wonder what's behind door number four
Oh climbing rope rope ladder good I can
use that to go down the hole that I
don't want to go into so that's a thing
apparently
but what thing is that gonna be for can
I like steal pieces of this cuz this
looks like I can steal pieces of it
can i play chard big stick long stick no
okay so anyway let's look at this
objectively now I have some other things
that I could do but I also have this
rope that I could use to go down into a
hole in the ground
maybe maybe oh I just jumped I literally
left why why was anything though maybe
that's just a root I could use to evade
the monster oh maybe I could use my long
stick to get this thing long stick get
it I found the item study key yay pray
for me where is there a locked door now
oh gosh darn it uh there was a locked
door over here maybe I could use it to
get over here hello
it won't open hobble below on the second
floor okay thank you for conveniently
placed instructions with any of the most
and then horrifyingly strange procedures
when I don't need them at all
okey dokey hey cookie alrighty then
oh I don't get me wrong I like this game
a lot it's actually very nice i I really
am enjoying myself a lot here's the
study Kate ooh this is a big something
ooh ain't you a big hunk of room over
here oh oh yeah I'm just wondering when
the butt stabber is gonna come up and
stab me in the butt repeatedly over and
over again why what happened
well broke oh that broke it revealed the
same good screws Phillips head
ah there was a thing on the other side
of the wall I remember
hi kitty cat I remember up wha-wha-wha
what the Frick if truck was that that
was new and horrifying Oh what was that
is that a kitty cat kitty cat Bowser
well go away forever not gonna hear you
screw you buddy what do we do what do we
do oh he goes astray logic he goes
that's right lines
you gotta try lines get away get away
get away get away get away get away
charge me bro charge me bro ah screw
your charging I'm not charging anyway
what am I gonna do oh I got me well is
this what you do oh yeah go you go he
charges he charges oh hi hi my friend
Lee yes whoo okay what we're gonna do is
I'm gonna do a little bit of olay action
over here and we're gonna aw or I'm
gonna just walk right into him that's
cool thing to that's something that I
could do how about we do dat never again
he's bum-rushing me okay this guy is
horrifying and I hate him yeah come back
kitty kitty come back you can blame it
all on me
you horrifying beast I'm going
downstairs
this guy I'm gonna have them charge to
the thing Oh didn't expect that move
over there good one guy you did great
congratulations on being a giant prick
okay so there's a specific route that I
think I need to go me okay now you come
oh you come out come out here I'm gonna
go in here then I'm gonna be around here
then I'm gonna go through here and then
I'm gonna push then I'm gonna go down
here then I'm gonna do and then I'm
gonna go to here and then I'm gonna go
down here and then when you charge me
over here
you're gonna get me new oh you missed it
you missed it you mr. doe Cato nope
ah-ha
whatever that was done but I almost had
him I almost had him I'm gonna make him
charge down there it's gonna work I know
it's gonna work that is the way that is
the truth in the way in the one way that
we are supposed to go
you're still freaky as [ __ ] but I mean
that's okay I guess I guess okay all
right okay get out of here you son of a
[ __ ] gun bastard bug nugget come on I'm
gonna come on car come on
I don't know Oh piss ball whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever god
this is it's hard to it's hard to
navigate them it's hard to get them to
go exactly on the center line that I
want them to go
yeah meow meow meow and hello okay we're
gonna do is we're gonna have a nice
little chat over here you're gonna come
with me
we're gonna go and have a happy fun time
come on come on come on do this do this
for me baby do this one now that no god
damn it meet wait maybe I think I might
be able to get him anyway maybe he won't
need to charge it after all I got it I
got it I got this I got this I have a
strategy employed maybe I don't need to
make him charge home maybe he'll walk
right into it huh maybe come back you
can blame it all on me that was Flo she
almost had me there buckaroo oh you're
quite quick one ain't ya well it's too
bad for you I am a professional bastard
anteye Oh what no you did it before what
the ball ah there's gonna take a while
I'm gonna get this guy I'm gonna get him
maybe or maybe I should just run away
from them maybe I should just do that
maybe that's a thing that I should do
how about we just do that let's just run
away from him so we think we can get
away though
how about that how about that whoops oh
whoops you seem to be going quicker now
you think oh I'm on the right strategy
mi well you're a go get me my go get my
I'm too quick I'm now blondie oh why did
blondie join the party nobody invited
blondie oh oh whatever
all right you know what I'm gonna figure
this out later
cuz I'm all out of time so I'll get to
it again later later so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Bob I haven't used this tons of detail
right here Oh
yeah it's a good idea to start banging
on the keyboard
thank you can't thank you enough for
coming out all this way to help me it's
been a pretty rough road trying to sell
this old place I wish you have turned in
sooner with no idea how happy I'll be
once this is all by me love you always
right putting a lot of backstory here at
the